joining me now gordon chang
gatestone institute senior fellow author
of the great u.s china tech war gordon
your reaction to what wang said there
and do you think
blinken was as tough as he needed to be
with his chinese counterpart today
blinken has never been as tough as he's
needed to be with the chinese the
reality is this week china has had a
frigate in japanese territorial waters
in the south east china sea around the
islands to send conquerors they've also
had their planes buzzing through
japanese airspace in the south china sea
this week they've had two of those large
coast guard vessels blocking the
resupply the philippine outpost in
second thomas shaw that's the reality
it's military force that the chinese are
using and when when wang talks about
cooperation he's lying through his teeth
wow talk to me for a moment about these
tariffs we've heard a lot about biden
considering lifting these tariffs first
of all why were those trump tariffs put
into place what were they designed to do
and what do we lose by lifting them
those tariffs under section 301 of the
trade act of 1974 they were there as a
remedy for the theft of u.s intellectual
property and also president trump wanted
to move supply chains on shore when
biden even just talks about lifting
those tariffs it says to u.s companies
stay in china i'm not going to let you
um have to worry and we are going to do
business as usual which means business
in china not business in the u.s
unbelievable no matter the trade record
the human
trafficking record the crushing of
religious and uh human rights it's it's
it's scandalous that they would even
contemplate lifting those tariffs back
in february biden's doj ended the trump
era
china initiative okay this is the group
within the fbi after civil rights groups
said it racially profiled asian
americans but the whole purpose was to
prosecute chinese espionage gordon
particularly our universities director
ray was asked about ending it and if it
was a mistake listen
we are not going to engage in profiling
by ethnicity or national origin
and we haven't
and we're going to work jointly with
universities
in many cases that's one of the most
effective ways
to prevent
stealing of of research which is in the
hands of our universities
and when law enforcement action is the
appropriate
tool to be used we're going to use that
tool
was it a mistake to end that initiative
doesn't seem that he's real willing to
really admit it oh absolutely what china
does is it uses chinese americans and
chinese nationals to commit espionage
against the u.s the 2017 national
intelligence law of china requires every
chinese national to spy if beijing makes
a demand we need to understand that what
biden did by ending the china initiative
was he's caving into beijing which
always says oh look you know you target
us this is just terrible well it isn't
terrible because we know what beijing is
doing i'm a chinese-american i
understand what they're doing this is
really wrong on the part of the biden
administration they should listen to you
and stop the endless dialogue which as
you've pointed out is a stall tactic
they've used for way too long gordon
chang thank you for being here hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else